our next experiment embraces one of the
most dangerous forces of nature almost 4
million people have watched red-hot lava
meet ice we caught up with artist Bobby
Saki and geologist Jeff Carson and
they're rumbling lava furnace to ask
them what they thought would happen I
had no idea what it was gonna do no idea
at all
the first guest as always it's going to
explode always number one or it's gonna
tunnel down it's just gonna dig right
through the I smell the hole in the ice
and of course it didn't do any of those
things
I was stunned by what it did when it hit
the ice then you see the bubbles it
bubbles this big then there's bubbles
within bubbles the scrambled eggs from
hell is the way it looks in that video
just two things we just didn't really
expect so why are volcanic bubbles
formed the lava is so hot that when it's
poured onto the ice the ice instantly
turns not just into water but straight
into steam
now this steam has to escape so it
bubbles through the lava so while it
looks like the lava itself is boiling
it's actually the steam being produced
that is trying to escape as the lava
cools we start to get a thick black
layer forming on top and this starts to
trap those bubbles of superheated steam
inside the rock and it's kind of like a
natural form of glassblowing should it
melt right through the formation of all
of this steam helps the lava to flow
because it means that it's sitting on
top of a blanket of steam rather than in
contact with the ice itself this means
the friction between the lava and the
ice service is very low now Bob and Jeff
were talking things to the next level
it's love versus water
we've done over a hundred pours into
water anti-santa sand onto snow we're
learning a lot there are things that are
happening here that we had not
anticipated it's beautiful stuff stand
back head sputtering lavas over 2,000
degrees Fahrenheit